going ashore that somebody else out
there doesn't feel alone and doesn't
need to live in perpetual fear if all of
us do that that's what changes this
country and that's what creates a team
so let me take off the clown mask no
it's been I'm not gonna like it's been a
tough spell it's been a tough spell for
a while
for me and I'm incredibly appreciative
when we do these live shows so U of M as
an example was really really hard
required getting a lot of people out
there 17 hour drive most of us flew
one-way drove the other way to try and
kind of pass it off and you know some
things some things could have gone
better that we had issue we've talked
about if you remember in MO club with
the Union numbers at U of M who didn't
let us get in we were supposed to get in
so that we were lining everything it
takes a crew of 12 people is very hard
and very draining physically and listen
not cancer nothing like that but I'm not
a guy who likes to necessarily in my
health isn't it's not in the best of
sorts right now these are things that
are that can be corrected but serious
enough to warm up you know I've taken
really a couple sick two sick days in
the history of this company a lot of the
time when people see we're not doing it
they don't realize this we actually
we're rebuilding something or were
actually taping something like I changed
my mind we just can't do it show the day
we do it change my mind or doing U of M
that was days and days of and getting
out several days of travel there might
be some more and and you know what let
me know who you would like to see as a
fill-in host um not right now but
probably around Christmas break and one
thing I will say though doing these live
shows which can be really exhausting and
they really can the reaction the
interactions with the the fans that
people are really incredible the people
who support the show Mugler I mean it
was crazy to me is at least 60 to 70
percent of people at that theater and by
the way had overflow thousands of people
were mug Club members oh yeah there was
a so that's not even just non Mugler
Club members get their hours in advance
so that's always it really is a team of
people we really do feel like it's
familial only overwhelmed by the support
but I also do notice an ongoing theming
you've probably seen this 2qa
particularly with the upcoming election
fear a theme of people being afraid and
a lot of different people a find
different ways to get over them a lot of
people fund
the show helps then I had some people
say listen man I just I'm so tired of
news and politics this was a veteran who
talked about how he had been suicidal I
actually have a Navy Cross there we
haven't figured that the perfect place
to put it yet so it's just safe so thank
you sir again for sending it but we're
gonna put it right next to that
befitting the ultimate warriors action
figure that mike Ward gave us that next
to a Navy Cross that crystallizes this
show some people say this show helps
them it's really important though this
isn't obviously the only I'm Sara P is
probably better than this show because
everyone on the show needs therapy so
understand the difference between being
afraid and I don't always get the chance
to answer people this way and being
afraid of something and being fearful
they're two different things and others
last segment of the week you know often
ends up be I think it ended up being
branded Crowder closes because people
were uploading it anyway like I want
those dollar dollar bills so I try to be
vulnerable I try to be earnest cuz I
don't think lies help I don't think
being completely disingenuous helps
I don't think false ego helps and
because I know a lot of you out there
might be experiencing some of the same
pain in in fears that I've gone through
or that I'm going through or people even
here sometimes in the studio so if it
helps you it'd be wrong for me to keep
it to myself
and I think a lot of you'll often go you
know don't don't be afraid oh listen to
be brave but they don't really tell you
how and if you have so let's say it's
you know the rock or someone like Daniel
Cormier so I really appreciate you
appreciate the interviews with Daniel
Cormier because Daniel Cormier is in a
world level ass-kicker
and on this show not always but on this
show he's been very vulnerable about
what it is that scares him about the
fact that he's nervous before every
fight very specific and I tell you what
for me that inspired me not about you
but hearing Daniel Cormier say I get
nervous before every fight I didn't feel
so bad about you know throwing up or
painting the porcelain before every
single live show in quarterblack noses I
don't enjoy
I don't enjoy speaking live I get very
very nervous when you get up there you
look really good well thank you I
appreciate the lies checks in the mail
it will clear you needn't same way
that's gonna clear anyway just like just
like a black belt from Steven Seagal
cleared and I'm amazing so if it does
help you the way daniel cormier brian
shard your sim pierre thomas so we've
had a lot of great people here who've
been we've actually talked specifically
about things they either scare them or
difficulties they've overcome um that's
been something it's been inspiring to me
and so I'm just gonna be honest were
there are a lot of things that scare me
but I don't live my life let me go
through it um and I'd like to you guys
uh tell me what it is it most gives you
going out on a limb here and I know
it'll be used against me eventually but
I also know that there's someone else
out there who probably feels like
they're alone might think that there at
the end of their rope and maybe this
will help so it's one person it's worth
it um I'm afraid if I'm afraid of being
alone that's something I'm really afraid
of this idea you know people talk about
being alone in a crowded room we often
hear in sound lyrics that often happens
I can be surrounded by a lot of people
Eno who a friend is or know who it's a
Sara Lee cares about me and especially
when you have so many supporters and I'm
grateful for them you're always afraid
that that goes away and that there's
just sort of dead still of quiet I've
always been very for me I'm afraid to be
alone I'm afraid of burning out it's one
of one of my worst fears I'm afraid of
burning out like after a University of
Michigan and again when you have kind of
health struggles nothing serious you
just it's hard it's sometimes it's hard
I can always get up and do the work that
I need to do as far as okay show up hit
the mark do the sketch fine write the
joke but when you don't have anything to
aim for sometimes it's really I just a
sink up right now okay where are we
gonna do the next change but what's the
next super video what where we gonna go
on location because so much needs to be
planned and it's it's just like you know
a lion-tamer it's the different legs of
this tool that keeps the line completely
confused that's the only reason that
this person isn't this circus clown is
not getting eaten I get overwhelmed
sometimes I'm afraid of burning out I am
afraid of not being deserving with this
platform frankly I'm afraid of that
something I've always been afraid of I
see the faces I see people who come up
when they they tell me their personal
stories and how much this program means
them I really am grateful but I'm a I
think I often feel undeserving I worked
really hard
you know I be I try to be honest with
people I probably work harder than
anyone I know and that's kind of a
reputation in the industry if you ask
other people I'm a Clydesdale not a show
horse clear
not an Arabian Prancer dancer whatever
it is all you equestrians I don't care
go do your distress but um I'm afraid I
often feel undeserving of the platform
I'm afraid of mistakes that I've made
which have harmed others and I I don't
necessarily know what they are sometimes
when you're in a leadership position
this keeps me up at night I'm afraid
that have made mistakes that have caused
ripple effects and they were mistakes
that I could've avoided especially when
you know you have employees and you're
and you're sure in your mid-20s you make
mistakes mistakes are okay but I I I
have trouble sleeping sometimes when I
think about I couldn't that's something
that bothers me a lot
I'm afraid the Brazilian Wandering
Spider that goes without saying I'm
afraid of not doing it not knowing when
I've done the right thing that's
something that's hard afraid of the
mistakes and sometimes not knowing if
you've made a mistake or done the right
thing because sometimes you make a
decision that you have to make for
someone else in the team or someone else
in your life that negatively affects one
other person sometimes sometimes it's
just like we don't have that much room
in the lifeboats sometimes you have to
make hard decisions and sometimes you
think you have to make hard decisions
and it's just wrong I'm afraid of that
I'm afraid of
I'm afraid frankly I used to have a bad
temper I'm afraid of it coming back I'm
afraid of mr. Hyde rearing his ugly
bisexual head that was a smoke that was
a short face no I'm afraid kind of
afraid of getting angry afraid of being
too emotional afraid of being obsessive
because that I'm afraid of alienating
friends family people who I care about
most something I think about a lot
sometimes a lot of pressure sometimes a
lot of compression comes hyper
volatility emotionally and I'm afraid of
pushing people away especially when you
have people who you love who either work
with you or in close proximity this is
I'm afraid of and this is why you might
have seen there was a pause at U of M
I'm afraid of having children I'm really
afraid of having children I said I don't
like kids that's not true I like kids
that's a smokescreen I kind of don't
like sticky kids but I'm afraid of
having children deathly afraid because
of thrusting them into a life that they
didn't choose I've had a lot of close
calls I've had even just not close calls
and had very unpleasant encounters we've
had people who just work for this show
who had been spat on we've had people
get violent with them we even at U of M
we had people trying to start a bar
fight for people who weren't even on
stage what they knew worked with the
crew I'm really afraid of having
children and bringing them into that
it's always been something of bothers me
because of that something else I'm
afraid of the fact that my fear of
having children could cause irreparable
damage with a wife who I know deserves
them not saying I'm never gonna have
kids by the way I'm just saying it's a
street it's a fear that I struggle with
I know a lot of people struggle with
these fears we talked about the church
groups often when people aren't honest I
need to be forgiven for being a
workaholic I spend too much on Facebook
you know what no I'm telling you exactly
what I'm afraid I'm telling up I'm
telling you what my weaknesses are
because I know and some of these are
actually things that I feel as though I
should have expressed a long time ago
because I constantly encounter these at
live performances where people say you
know what I really struggle with this
and you help me with it I'm going you
know and I should just tell people I
should just tell people that I struggle
with that I just tell people that I
struggle with with burnout and fear of
that or I should just tell people that
I'm afraid of having children because it
might help them to not feel so alone
here that's so much from the left oh
don't be alone only they trying to tell
you shouldn't feel alone in your
depravity
I'm telling you shouldn't feel alone of
being afraid of things but hopefully
there's a solution that we'll get to
after this I'm afraid I'm afraid of all
of this going away and 15 people being
out of a job that's one thing that
really scares me if I'm undeserving oh
it all goes away or you say the wrong
thing that can happen to anyone these
days we've been really blessed there's
15 other people who rely on mug Club and
your support not just myself that's
something that's really scary here's how
you know me and on this I'm afraid of
not being able to discern the things
that I can control and the things that I
can't and wasting energy trying to fix
things or trying to contain things that
I can't control
I'm really afraid of not having
discernment or not having perfect
discernment I think that's what a lot of
these fears stem from and even more I
think I'm I'm afraid of not fixing the
issues that I can control and that would
be even harder to live with so it's a
vicious it's just this never-ending
cycle of what can
control what can I not and if you can
control it you better do something about
it because people are relying on you to
fix this and it's out of your control
you're spinning your wheels and the
people who are relying on you they're
just gonna see you burn out and then you
can't help them it's it's a really
difficult thing to break it's a really
difficult cycle to break I'm afraid of
all of these things and snake island but
I don't live in fear and neither should
you and I hear this a lot particularly
this election you shouldn't live in it's
okay to be afraid of things everyone is
afraid bravery is doing the right thing
in the face of being afraid but living
in perpetual fear is different just like
people tell lies but lying to yourself
consistently is corrosive to your soul
in a way that is very different from
telling somebody they don't look fat in
a dress living in a state of fear is
different from being afraid you do not
have to live in fear regardless the
election because you're not alone and
not only are you not alone because of
whether you believe in him or not God
says that you're not alone
but let's get out of you know what
people may see as corny sort of
metaphysical bumper stickers if you're
watching this live right now okay look
at how many people are watching live
with you if you're watching the show
afterward just look at how many
subscribers mug clubbers there are next
to you take solace of knowing there are
millions upon millions of people right
now in arms with you and you know why
those people hit the subscribe button
you know what those people have bought
this isn't it's it's awesome it's hand
etched it's girthy it's hand painted
this is just a symbol
you know what millions of people have
supported this program it's not because
it's it's it's funny every now and then
we get a few right it's not because
people feel so this is the only place
they can go for political information or
insight millions of people have signed
up because they have been through
something similar to what you are going
through or to what you have been through
look at that subscriber count that's the
ceiling right now on YouTube I just lost
my pen the ceiling for conservatives on
YouTube is our channel right and that's
also a burden that scares us because
we're going way over we're changing the
blueprint every single week and we're
trying to do right by it
elections fluctuate and we get so many
emails especially the life advice but
what what did I do with the election I
feel that our country's done I hear that
every single election
she's change parties change and it goes
back and forth but win lose or draw
whether it's disk or on the next
go-around you're not alone you don't
need to live in fear do you feel better
at all does that help you feel better I
know sometimes usually feel-good
segments but it doesn't really matter
okay because will you feel better or not
that's the truth so take it if you feel
better good
now it's your obligation to help the
next guy go make sure today right now if
you're listening if you're watching this
show immediately let me pause this
there's only gonna be a few seconds of
music afterward anyway you don't even
need to hear it you've probably heard a
song a million times with Pogo pause it
right after this phrase and immediately
going ashore that somebody else out
there doesn't feel alone and doesn't
need to live in perpetual fear if all of
us do that
that's what changes this country and
that's what creates a team and that's
what gives people not only self belief
but belief in their values and belief in
real change make sure today right now
this is the last phrase I'm getting near
the end of this now name that movie line
that you go out and ensure someone else
doesn't feel alone and doesn't have to
live in fear because that's why we do
this this video subscribe hit the
notification bell or if you want to
continue to enjoy free content support
us at a lot of credit calm /mo Club or
you get the full nightly show an hour
every day free along with all of our
friends content if not you don't want to
do any of those things you're probably
just here you're watching me seething
you came here to hate watch that being
said the internet was created for people
like you